all right uh so yeah let's get going the
first talk in this room is Andy
fundinger talking about adventures in
not
testing
uh there we okay so welcome uh welcome
back to P data last day first well first
talk after the Keynote um so who am I hi
I'm Andy fundinger uh I've been
programming python I think it's more
useful to give you a version in a year
so I've been working I started with
python 24 and I started with a book that
said Learn Python version
2.2 newly updated for python
so at the time I was working on plone
which is a Content management system for
my company at the
time uh I've done some stuff with
Twisted I've done a lot of stuff in the
financial
industry uh about 2017 I came over to
Bloomberg uh initially I worked with a
product called Data license it's
basically would you like Bloomberg data
here's Bloomberg
data uh about
2019 I I caught a hint of the system
reliability engineering and I said oh
that that looks interesting I can fix
things that are broken and figure out
what's broken which just appeals to
me uh and then in uh 2020 I went over to
our data Services Group um which is
really very similar it's uh you're in
Bloomberg
well um you're in Bloomberg you want
data get data we'll give it to you uh so
we've run a data Gateway kind of sits in
the middle of many Bloomberg workflows
we're Gateway we don't own the code
above us that asks for data we don't own
the code below us that gives us data we
only getting the requests
through um and there's a lot of requests
there's billions of requests a day
there's millions of semi-independent
code paths through code that we don't
actually
own uh so a lot of what I do is I take
in Telemetry data I take in information
about what the system see seems to be
doing and I try to progress from
there
um so that's a lot of
analysis uh we'll talk about that
because that's where we're going but
about this talk first of all show of
hands who only read the title and
decided to come to this talk okay you're
going to have a slightly different
experience from the people who read the
title and the
description um
um
so this talk is about how to not write
tests but really it's about how to
reduce the time we take to right tests
with a couple tools that I I think are
useful and I think are very
useful in and around data science and
Analysis code uh so despite the title we
will be writing tests we will be
creating tests but we will get some help
writing
them uh so I'm going to I'm going to
refer to my main example as analysis
code uh what I'm talking about is where
you start with a question questions that
I get are like what does latency look
like what what do we rely on these are
questions in human language that don't
have specific like I'm going to run I'm
going to use this methodology I'm going
to do this I peer reviewed what I'm
going to do I know what I'm going to do
so we don't know what the answer is we
don't know what the question is and we
might only need it once because we're
going to discuss it at a meeting and
then make some
decisions sometimes it makes sense to
not write tests while you're writing
this code because you're doing some
averages you're looking at like the 99
percentile and then you're like oh no
maybe I should look at the 90th
percentile until you get something that
explains what you're
seeing and that's your answer and you're
done of course once you've done this
it's not uncommon that someone's going
to look at and go
so could you make a little change in
this could you run it on a subset could
you brute by like heavily loaded versus
lightly loaded could you run this every
day on the day's data output the
information and and send it around for
the whole company to look
at at that point you already know you
should have tests so this this request
brings you from it didn't make sense to
write tests to I should have written
tests and that's kind of the pit that I
I want to suggest a way out
of
um but we still don't know what the
future data is going to look like we
neither know what we might be asked to
run on on the future in the future
nor what data might actually come in
because it's the
future
so uh the example code that will pop up
from time to time here I just generated
10,000 samples of some kind of
requests uh and I I used the loose
question uh what how would the system
perform at various
capacities uh I said okay some clients
are batch some clients are timely it's a
batch client it could roll over and the
thing thing we think is interesting
is how long is the system 100% loaded
after you take what came in and what's
rolling
over we we will never actually look at
the full code but some people I think
will better understand if they're not
worrying about what the code might
do and the main tool we're going to use
is
hypothesis I will'll do show of hands
again how many people have heard of
python hypothesis Library before oh cool
okay great
um so this is copied right from their
website basically what hypothesis does
is lets you say the data should look
like
this and then it should run through my
test and and I have some idea what
happens so a normal test you say uh I'm
going to set this up I'm going to create
this input okay that's
great then and I'm going to run it
through this code and then some things
will be true also it won't
crash um hypothesis says I'm going to
say what the data should look like
hypothesis is going to create hundreds
of variations of what I said the data
should look like it's going to run it
through this
code a it shouldn't crash uh but B I can
make some assertions about what should
always be true uh either based on the
data that came in or based on what my
analysis is supposed to do uh this is
also known as property based testing and
uh it originated with the Quick Check
library in
hasal so how does this help well it
relieves us of having to create test
data
so if we create test data we're going
okay so what does the data look like
okay let me make something that looks
like the data looks like and we're not
going to create the what kind of data
would cause this error what's the
weirdest thing that might get sent to us
what did I say should work but like no
no we're never going to get a net a
negative net
sales in our cach registers that
wouldn't make sense so you didn't put in
the test data well we don't have to make
those decisions up front we can tell
hypothesis we take floating Point
numbers so we describe what might be
valid and we let hypothesis work it out
from there so this is the hypothesis
floating Point number strategy here's an
example you said it could take floating
Point numbers can it take 10^ the
308 uh let's take another example how
about uh 1 to the negative
uh 1 *
107 oh and it's
negative uh you said it would take flows
um how about not a number is that a good
float hypothesis will take care of
making sure that it feeds those in
eventually and in fact hypothesis is
almost
pathological uh so it will go hey how
about infinitees how about
10-38 how
about if everything in the input is
infinity
um but but we're still writing tests
here and I I said we were adventuring
and not writing tests I have to get at
least partially there uh hypothesis has
a tool called
Ghostwriter it installs a script called
hypothesis when you pip install it
hypothesis. write it writes test and how
it writes
tests you give it a python
function or module and it writes the
test for them so here is a hypothesis
test for
sorted written by a
ghost hypothesis right sorted and this
is what they look like given an iterable
which is
either a sequence of integers or a
sequence of
floats uh sorry sequence of integers or
a sequence of
texts
um given a key which is a key function
but the type hinting in the standard
Library says that's always a none and we
won't fix that on this
example and given reverse which is
either true or
false we should be able to run
sorted and it should all
work
um so El right hypothesis feeds in data
there are no assertions
the ghost cannot know what your codee's
supposed to do other than not crash
which may be an
improvement uh let's take another
example uh this is what you get if you
try to run on the math ceiling
function uh we should know what ceiling
does um but they didn't type Hint it so
it says the strategy is nothing strategy
nothing fails
test right off the bat um
but it did go ahead and create the
boiler plate
code
um we can fix this ceiling takes
floating Point numbers and now we can
say we assert no matter what number you
take if you get the sealing of it your
output will be greater than or equal to
the
input we could make some more assertions
but this will be true and now we can run
it and this is run through P test and we
get uh not just one failure we actually
get two
failures uh it turns out you cannot
convert not a number to an integer it uh
raises a value error and infinity raises
an overflow error so we would then go
and say okay well this is the proper
behavior I mean I picked something from
the standard Library so I'm not going to
fix the code but I do need to fix the
tests so now I would say a hypothesis
test with
given
um do not take not a numbers do not give
me Infinity those are not valid for this
test and add two standard tests below
that say if you are given a not a number
then you must raise a value
error okay so we'll go ahead I've got
one more here this is just to show how
it writes out a group by also
takes um iterables and
runs
um moving into something that might be
our code now I'm going to I'm going to
apologize for our code here I went on
vacation to
Portugal and I made sure to write it
when I was really relaxed so I I would
be sure there were bugs in the
code um so this is a function that I
came up with again on
vacation um for finding the longest how
many TRS and how many falses there are
in a row you can write a better one uh
but this has bugs and that's
good um so it's tyght pinted I said this
takes an itable of
bulls and it does its thing uh should I
have people raise hands if they can see
the bug in
here there is a bug okay well hypothesis
will show us in two slides uh but first
it'll create us a test here's a
test um these are all the different
things that iterables could be now I
actually feed this Panda
series uh pulled out of a data
frame but these are all different
iterables and I type ined it to say
iterables so all of these should work
hypothesis will test all of
these and when hypothesis does so
oh key error
Falls uh if you actually feed it an
empty
sequence there's no true or
false back
here sure cuz I was going to write a
test if feated an empty sequence or
something I never expected to send an
empty sequence because I got 10,000 data
points that was on my list so here we'll
probably fix the code I'm sure there's a
bug still in this um and it's certainly
inefficient but that will return if
there were none then
it's uh
zero but uh the sequences are all well
and good but we use data frames an awful
lot so let's try data
frames yep there we go it read my typ
hinting it all it was a data frame it
said here's a strategy from type data
frame go ahead use
that this will create data frames and it
will feed them
in and it will find an error in this
function uh because it turns out if you
take an empty data frame and you tell
the code to
um sum up along a list that has
something in it it will notice that the
column's not there and uh that that's a
failure obviously so we should probably
fix
that um there's the
code
um but let's take a look at this from
type
strategy if we just run this from type
strategy we can get an example and we
can see what it gives us it gives us an
empty data
frame every
time well that's not going to get us
very far we could have just given it an
empty data frame so we'll make our own
data
frame with columns and
so we can do that winds up being quite a
bit of code um so I I changed my test I
said my test takes a list of client
names takes a list of floats that are
going to fill into the data frame takes
a list of of true false are these
batch um takes those puts them together
looks at the true false to make the list
of batch clients that it has to send in
then it knows what the clients are so it
can use the clients and it can fill
those float values in row by row to make
up a data frame yeah yeah we can do that
and it
works there's one of the test data
frames that's created by that method um
I probably would find some bugs I doubt
that I'm set up for those Infinities and
not a
numbers
um and we can even make some assertions
about
it
um so this is uh just cutting off the
bottom of that test function we can
assert that whatever the total
is
it's the the sum of the batch and the
time
uh traffic whatever that is comes up to
the total summing across the whole data
frame it should all sum out
somehow we can make the assertion hey
um the total the Max total should be
higher than or equal to the
batch Max and same thing for timely that
all makes sense because where was my
code
uh at the end of the day this is this is
the function we're expecting calculate
totals we
Bally and
total so we'll go ahead and run this and
uh yeah we got a couple assertion errors
here
um first of all if we get an not a
number and we try to add something to
the not number
uh you can't make a comparison anymore
because you can't compare n the
numbers um
also you can't compare two non numbers
if everything comes up
empty
so I'm sorry the first one is not not
numbers the first one is if I feed
infinity and
infinity you even if you add up Infinity
it's not a number and you can't use
it so infinite usage is probably not a
thing I don't know I'm making the
assumption that I will not allow
infinite usage into here because it's
not clear what one would
do um
so I can go and I can say allow Infinity
false feed this
in and then I'm going to make the other
assumption that if I get a not a number
I want a zero so I'll go ahead and
change now my code to say not a
number I'll also
say if I get batch clients that are not
even in the columns that's fine I'll
only work on the ones that are in the
columns that'll solve that earlier
error and we still have one more bug
here it turns out that if you have a
negative
number um it will
not
uh you can get a maximum total
of
-1 and your batch can be
zero so we're also going to say that we
don't let negative numbers in here
because we know what our input source is
and we know that negative usage is not a
thing for
us now we have a test but we're not
going to keep doing
that uh hypothesis extra pandas can let
us just create data frames out of out of
whole cloth and with the help of
hypothesis
so the different function estimate
needed capacity it only actually looks
at the total column so we say pandas
data frames columns we Define one column
it's total data type uh float 64
there um and then we take a percentile
now percentile only makes sense between
zero and one so we can go ahead and
Define that right off the top now we
have a function and we can run it and uh
you may have picked up the the pattern
in this talk almost always the first
time we V it we get a
bu um in this case if you calculate the
percentile of an empty data frame that's
also not a
number so again we'll make a check we'll
say if it's
empty return zero and move
on
okay um another case that we run into is
sometimes you put together the data and
what you put together when you look at
it with the tools you have available up
and given you're going to create
something that doesn't make sense and
hypothesis gives us an assume function
for that
so we have a function that's called
enrich capacity we're looking at the
capacity of something again made up
example but it's not interesting if we
have plenty of
capacity we we don't need to test you
know what if you have infinite capacity
you
don't you don't need to to test if you
have capacity far in excess of your
usage so we put this together we have
total batch timely same as the output of
the the earlier
function and we're just going to assume
the capacity is at
most 10% more than the highest number in
the whole data frame
cuz if it's more than that it's all
going to be the
same you can also use this to skip
something that you know will fail
because it doesn't make
sense uh and and we're winding down here
uh there's a couple hypothesis tools I
want to mention but I am not
demonstrating
um there's Target an example Target will
let you say please run tests like this
example will say include this one
of course you could just write a
separate test to do that um but these
are useful for reproducing things um
especially if something failed in Ci or
on someone else's desktop and you want
to make sure that that one's being run
because
otherwise hypothesis
is following a couple processes first
it's randomly doing some
things it's including anything that
failed previously because it keeps a
cache so you will not Escape your
failures with
randomization and then once it found
something it makes some additional runs
to try to narrow it down and find the
simplest
example um there's also register type
strategy what register type strategy
will let you do is if when you type hint
you use a type definition create a new
type you can say this is how you create
these so if you have a final customer
usage data frame or something you can
say that's the type and then hypothesis
will create that for
you um there's also settings for timing
and randomization so you can say don't
randomize just always run what you would
consider uh from this seed or something
uh
timing is one I wind up using a fair
amount if you're testing something
complex you can tell hypothesis yes you
based an error because running this test
took longer than hypothesis defaults to
but please just keep going um I know
it's taking a long time for my tests but
it it's worth it to
me uh so
conclusions do WR
tests do use test driven development
where
appropriate uh if you know something is
going to be used if you know what you're
doing go ahead write the test first it's
probably less
hassle upfront even than anything that
can be done here however do go ahead and
use
hypothesis
um rather than or in addition to
selected examples all this is driven off
your type
hints um it's probably worth it at the
same time you're putting in
documentation put in type in thre
hypothesis make some tests off of
those
um and of course the big takeaway here
if you don't know what data you might
get hypothesis lets us
describe everything that could be valid
should be valid and then we'll run the
test off of
that and uh this brings us down to Q&A
so somewhere there's a
microphone have it um let's see this
this if I turn this on let see if it's
uh is yours I I think so okay cool any
questions I'm wondering if there's a way
to specify a maximum number of tests and
hypothesis will run
yes um I think it's mostly specified in
terms of time I think by default it
comes out to it's either 100
milliseconds or half a second that it'll
sit there just banging away so you would
say like okay I only want you to run 10
milliseconds on
this uh and it splits the time in half
the first half it uses to find tests the
second half it uses to narrow down to
the best example can give
you thank
you I can just yell um go ahead is there
any way for hypothesis to say you want
to run the same test run three times
with the same input into hypothesis and
then have it randomize again or is it on
every iteration that it randomizes so
the question was as I understand it if
you want to run the exact same code with
the exact same input three times because
some is non-deterministic beneath that
yeah okay
uh it wouldn't surprise me if there was
a setting for that but I'd probably just
put a for Loop in my
test um true um it's sounds like there's
or you
know thank you for this um so I think
you can create your own custom
strategies um but to what degree do you
usually end up doing that and kind of
related to this is the little that I
have tried to use it and doing with like
uh scientific Computing you want to like
maybe Define something drawn from a
distribution and it wasn't at least
immediately apparent to me how to tell
it to like make distributional
assumptions and and what it generates
so I essentially when you're making a
data frame as I showed uh you are
defining your own
strategy um
you're essentially defining your own
strategy for creating your data frames
right there so I do that a fair amount
I've been using this basic approach on
my own work for like six to n
months
um that much is true if I need something
to conform to a
distribution I would probably use an
input like of a seed which is is a float
and just feed that seed
into something that creates that
distribution for me um there I think
there is a statistics extension similar
to the pandas extension which may for
the more common distributions may be
fine if you're looking for the normal
distributions uh but I would probably
just create it in a
test any other
questions once one twice cool let's
thank the speaker
again